oh dude I forgot to tell you in La Jolla
ya see this group walk in 25 older white
people like that's weird not my demo
they go they bought tickets months ago
one of the older guys is a fan his whole
family's here for Christmas
they don't know who you guys are but
they brought he brought 25 tickets all
right cool Jesus sure took tickets away
from real fans
whatever they want to add at the show
anyway the song goes up you know a song
nice Indian fellow from San Jose goes up
has a bit reference in a play with a
Nazi in it and says some reference it's
funny bit
that's it reference Nazi one of the
older white girl I remember that one
older what you've heard is bit yeah well
the older white ladies in the crowd it
gets logos
what's wrong with Nazis what's wrong
with Nazis ha but I'm not you know I'm
not like not like kathlynn be like
what's wrong with not like if you said
something about black people or Asians
like what's wrong with Asians you know
like dead serious they couldn't you know
what's wrong with not seasoned the whole
crowd thing uh and it's Anya's excuse me
she doubles down what's wrong with Nazis
and he's like roast her a little bit but
then ignores it
she keeps heckling keep technically I'm
in the back watch I have security if she
keeps doing that I don't give a [ __ ] how
many tickets they bought you gotta get
them out of there we can't have this
that's right they go we'll focus on it
all right Derrick goes up you know
Derrick you know yeah Derrick goes up
does a reference about you know
something he's talking about something
she has him he says something out her
being a Nazi Baba he keeps going she
takes up martini glass
throws it as hard as she can at him and
she's probably where chin is to me she
hits him with Mario that's a [ __ ] yeah
and the whole crowd just booing her
boner Derrick off see lights are up back
on stage and she not get thrown out she
got thrown out oh she just done it yeah
cops got called yeah that's a real piece
of [ __ ] that I was thinking alright
those other 24 older white people are
left the price [ __ ] 60
oh she's not at school not see yeah and
it's been a bad drunk yes a couple that
up when you put an Indian guy in a black
guy up there and then I look she's not
happened and then they saw that but I
thought maybe the whole squad was like
they're like oh God
so I go up there right so I'm making fun
of them I get off they say nothing they
see nothing after that she is thrown out
show goes fantastic because that gave us
material right shows fantastic I get
offstage they're all waiting in like oh
[ __ ] some of the you guys about to watch
me [ __ ] up 24 older white neo-nazis
get ready everybody get your camera's
out yeah they were so embarrassed they
were it was like a company thing they
were so in they're like we're so sorry
they were there just to apologize yeah
they're like we didn't know we had no
idea she's dealing with some stuff you
know we don't know her that well she was
like Nazis things you know went you and
deal and stuff on well she's a Nazi so
yeah she's dealing with some stuff
he was probably find a group for her Wow
Wow
they won't let us know what we can do a
buy more to it don't buy merch I don't
you rockin my [ __ ] and then when I leave
when they said heil hitler i'm like well
that was why there i was weird their
Heil Hitler
there it is yeah yeah they crazy all
right who stepped the hell crazy yeah
it's funny though I like I don't know
what it is a Genoa do you feel the
tension in the crown House like oh this
is cool this is where like some of the
worst scenes been at the comedy store
and I loved those crowds always really
loose but you get certain you get some
people a lot of military a lot of bros
well yeah this one girl that we had a
lot of military there this one girl who
I didn't know who was a feature when I
first did stand-up there are like and
maybe she was the emcee or so you guys
are making fun of the military this was
10 15 years ago 15 years ago being fun
oh well she was being like really bad
about it too like full of POW and these
Rangers were there and that they were
usually play but they weren't [ __ ]
happening she wasn't funny what you just
like can't do that so anyway there was
uh there were two or two
there were two marine through there
before who are so hammered they were
just like guys got to go well then they
DME like dude we are hammered they
kicked us out
we've been frayed I'm like I can't
control there is there is a rusty dually
remember rusty doing [ __ ] hilarious I
love rusty bring is not rusty rusty was
always a comic store regular and and
great and and there's this there's this
woman this [ __ ] in the front I will
never forget this she's an [ __ ]
and she's she's just being such a pain
yes and he goes he just finally goes
okay I'm stopping until you leave and
she goes you're joking they're his and
as he goes you're joking and he goes no
ma'am I'm not that shredded rusty was
always working out he would he would
jump rope for one hour straight he held
that but he's such a good guy I love him
and look I got a total Comics comic like
that you know and he he goes no ma'am
I'm not joking I'm a professional
comedian and I'm not joking so I'm gonna
sit here until they throw you out oh
[ __ ]
and she goes no follow she was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and and so she says my husband's
a Navy SEAL you [ __ ] and and her
husband gets up he gets up he is just a
little thick he's just a little thick
with a shaved head and he's older he's
probably 38 maybe 40 probably not still
in service no he's still in the service
okay and they're with another couple
this guy's big - oh well so they get up
and he says something like she says yeah
you're lucky yeah you got you watch your
mouth and he goes well you should watch
your mouth I mean you know I'm surprised
your husband doesn't slap it for you
right now the guy stops turns and looks
and yes and he starts to move towards
the stage rusty who's smaller than I am
yeah thinner than I tell you the small
yes he gets into sort of a stance I you
know me I look Brennan I'm telling you
if you go what do you do but he was he
went come on come on cuz rusty
cagey and rusty doesn't give a [ __ ] so
cut rusty go on let's go come on he's
doing this he's like he's got one hand
out and he's waving him in like this
like a karate and and but but rusty was
pissed and I I took one look at this
guy's back and neck and you better be
Brennan shop if we want to fight this
guy he's that thick I mean you better be
Brendan jump in then yeah I mean yes
you're gonna see these a Navy SEAL he's
probably a SEAL team 6
who knows what he is he's been in the
teams a long time which means you're
gonna lose an eye and maybe get your
nose bit off if he starts to lose its
not gonna be he's picked these guys
waited for [ __ ] keeps maybe he's got
a knife whatever the case violence is
not something he's a stranger to know so
Russ he's gonna get eaten
I'm getting eaten but you know me I have
a big ego down for it well I'm not down
for anything but I'm I have to do
something because I kill your friend you
as much as I talk as much as I train
yeah I have to do something yeah but so
the bouncers somehow calm him down and
move him to the back although you let
them stay but the bouncers are guys like
they're not even bouncers than that
they're they're just dudes who are
working though so now he he looks at he
looks at and goes now you don't think
what he said was offensive [ __ ] to my
wife you want me to get offensive now
who do you say that to to the bouncer to
the bigger guy who was also the man okay
he's like you kid want me to get
offensive now here's what scared me I
was behind them I knew I was gonna have
to jump on you I was thinking I was
thinking rear naked choke yeah good luck
against Navy SEAL dude his neck was he
didn't have a neck he was and he was so
wide he's like he probably weighed he
was at eight he was Tim Kennedy a little
taller I'm not kidding
Tim Kennedy at six foot six yep um you
got problems
so I'm my heart's racing because I I
have to do something because none of
these other bouncers are and I'm not
gonna be able to do it so he gets he
gets in the guy's face and he goes do
you want me to you want me to be
offensive and what scared me was at his
buddy and the guy's wife and the buddy
was big they were trying to calm him
down
and it was and they were so afraid they
were afraid hold huh they were afraid
they're like oh no here's here comes
Carl they were
five they were like please please no
don't it's not what's cooking they were
like the way you would don't please
don't do a dog like a huge dog that's
growling at you about the biters and
when I saw a theory before yeah when I
saw that I went oh this is a disaster
oh oh um I don't know what to do tha'll
Sam please last time you wanted 4015
please well thanks God the cops came
thank God unkind cops ma'am
why was that confrontational Wow and he
by the way this is stealing give a [ __ ]
this is a walk out is sealed the way he
moved out of that like he took his sweet
[ __ ] time looked at the cops like
this they knew the cops knew what he was
about they can see everything well in
that area too it's like yes yeah he said
he's innate and but but like there are
seals and then there are the guys
they're the operators have been in the
teams for a long time and you're like
yes you know soul Snatchers he's got a
he's got a little satchel with a bunch
of souls in it I was just like [ __ ] dude
I've seen some crazy [ __ ] say this thing
I've seen yet that lady the the pro-nazi
does it crazy I think Derek kept the
martini 12-david off and I had some some
times when we were young men we had some
weekend's there I can you not uh I say
it the pantry ah I do it what we walk
around great coffee great food the best
the best right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue Oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]